I was hoping you're gonna ask if you had
on here the the Richie incognito thing
with that that's that guy it sounds like
a spy I know that's like a great
wrestling name isn't it yeah like a
manager um yeah he like he's like a
300-pound dude and he's bullying another
300 pound dude oh I did hear about that
understand now you notice about that
whole thing I don't think it's any my
business you don't mean that was a
private phone call you know and then you
put it on TV dude if you took 90% of my
text messages and phone messages and you
put them on the news you would run out
of podiums to put in front of me that I
would have to apologize let me in to
Rosa say to each other fat it enough is
so bad if you have code you know what's
crazy as I knew that yeah I'm closing up
with Joe where he's like look at the
fake name yeah
does everybody here getting silent like
you don't do the same thing you know I
dunno oh yeah everybody has yeah you got
your little Paula Deen moments you got
something you know everybody coming down
on that chef like they're a perfect
person I miss the days when an apology
mo a Paula Deen moment was when you put
a pie on a windowsill to cool it was a
simpler time